SETH VARGO: Hey, everyone,
and welcome back.
Today we have Jaice with us.
And we're here to talk about
the community, diversity
and inclusion efforts, and
how Google's giving back.
Jaice, why don't you
introduce yourself.
JAICE SINGER DUMARS:
Thinks, Seth.
So I'm Jaice Singer DuMars.
I work in cloud
native strategy, and I
worked for Sara
Novotny, who is one
of the seminal members of
the Kubernetes community
who helped create what we think
of as a Kubernetes community
now.
So a lot of those things.
So basically I spent
every day learning
about all the amazing
things she does.
And so that's where I
start from, is that spot.
SETH VARGO: Awesome.
So aside from Sara,
what's your favorite part
about the Kubernetes community?
JAICE SINGER DUMARS: What I've
heard from a lot of people
is that this is one of the
best open source Kubernetes
to come in as a complete
beginner even to coding
or to community
itself and to feel
like you have a home,
that people care
about your progression in the
community and all the things
that you care about as well.
SETH VARGO: What are some
things that Kubernetes
is doing to help
advance equality,
help expand diversity,
and make sure
that it's an
inclusive environment?
JAICE SINGER DUMARS:
Well, this year
we bootstrapped the Kubernetes
Code of Conduct Committee.
So we actually have a
group of five people who
are focused on making
sure that those things are
evident across the
community, as well as having
really strong policies and
processes in place around that.
So that's really great.
I'm one of the five people.
Paris Pitman from
Google is also on there.
So that's great we have
Google representation on that.
SETH VARGO: Awesome.
It sounds like there's a
lot of Google representation
and Kubernetes obviously
on the technical side,
but also from the
community side as well.
What are some
other ways in which
Google is getting
involved and helping out?
JAICE SINGER DUMARS: Well, we've
helped the mentorship program
move forward, so
that is a great entry
point for a lot of
people who want to get
involved in the community.
And then again, Paris
Pitman is a dynamo.
She does so much work for
the contributor experience
special interest group.
And basically we are
constantly seeking out
opportunities where
we can widen the net
and bring more people
into the community.
SETH VARGO: Awesome.
So one last question.
JAICE SINGER DUMARS: Sure.
SETH VARGO: If you could
share one piece of advice
to someone new to
the community--
maybe it's a student
or maybe it's
someone who's been
in the industry
for 50 years-- what's one thing
that you would say to them?
JAICE SINGER DUMARS:
I'd say that don't
be afraid to talk to
anybody in the project.
If somebody is seen as a
luminary like Tim Hawkin
or Brian Grant or
the thought leaders,
they're completely approachable.
And everybody in the
project is the same way.
So if you have a question,
it doesn't matter who it is.
This is a community where
you could ask it and get
it answered in a good way.
SETH VARGO: Awesome.
Thank you very much, Jaice.
JAICE SINGER DUMARS:
My pleasure, Seth.
Thanks